look at this colorful cube its
three-dimensional as it occupies space
now we will observe this cube from three
different directions we will look at the
top view the front view and the right
view let's get started how would this
cube look if you were viewing it from
the top all we would see is the top face
which is a square the top view of this
cube is a square okay let's come back to
the original position
how put the cube look if we view it from
the front we would see just the front
face which is also a square the front
view is also a square and how would it
look if we view it from this site a
square again where do we look at it from
the top view or the front view or the
right view of the cube we will always
see a square so this involves a bit of
imagination and we should try this out
with different figures here is another
figure an empty glass take a moment and
think about how the top view would look
yes all we would see is a circle this is
the top view and if the top wasn't
covered we will see the circle of the
base as well and what about the front
view pause the video and give it a
thought this is what we would see a
trapezium two sides parallel and two non
parallel and the view from the right
again it would be a trapezium no matter
which side you look at it from we will
always see a trapezium so imagining the
views was pretty easy here how about we
make it a bit more exciting I will be
placing a few colored cubes on this
plain surface to form a figure okay so
here it goes
I place two red cubes here one yellow
cube on top and one blue cube here this
is the solid we will be referring to for
this example we have two red cubes one
yellow cube and a blue one now we need
to draw the top view the view from the
front and the view from the right how
would the top view look pause the video
and try to draw it in your notebook
let's try drawing it without moving the
figure if we look at it from the top we
will have the yellow square at the
bottom we draw a yellow square here and
this red cube will not be seen from the
top as the yellow one is covering it
next to the yellow square we have the
top face of the red cube so we draw the
red square face here and to the right of
the top face of the red cube we have the
top face of the blue cube so we draw a
blue square here this will be the top
view if we take the camera on top we can
see that our figure is correct now let's
get back to the original view looking at
this I want you to try drawing the view
from the front and the view from the
right okay let's draw the front view
first the front view is the view from
here at the bottom we have the front
face of this red cube so we draw a risk
where here imagine you're standing here
now from the front view what will we see
on the top of the red cube it will be
the front face of the yellow cube so we
draw a yellow square on top of the red
one and at the bottom next to the front
face of the red cube we will see the
front face of the blue cube we draw a
blue square here and that completes the
front view let's rotate the figure to
verify our answer yes we are right and
what about the view from the right in
the same way when we view the figure
from the right we will get a red yellow
and blue face like this how will the
view from the right look this is the
view from the right notice that the
front view and the right view look the
same drawing views from different angles
simply requires a little bit of
imagination and with enough practice you
will surely excel at it
[Music]